Uno de los grupos que mostraré muy rápidamente
es este increíble grupo de retratos
que encontramos en los museos de todo el mundo.
Si pudieras aumentar un poco más, Cyril.
Solo para mostrarles, Uds. pueden simplemente viajar por los retratos.
Y, esencialmente, pueden ir a naturaleza, caballos
y múltiples combinaciones.
Cuando vimos todos estos retratos,
pensamos: "¿Podemos hacer algo divertido para los niños,
o algo lúdico
para que la gente se interese en los retratos?".
Porque no he visto
niños pequeños realmente entusiasmados con ir a una galería de retratos.
Quería encontrar algo mejor.
Por eso hemos creado algo llamado comparador de retratos.
Es bastante autoexplicativo,
por eso dejaré que Cyril muestre su hermoso rostro.
Y esencialmente lo que sucede es, que mediante el movimiento de la cabeza,
comparamos diferentes retratos de los museos de todo el mundo.
(Aplausos)
Y yo no sé Uds.,
pero le he mostrado esto a mi sobrino y hermana,
y su reacción es simplemente fenomenal.
Todo lo que me preguntan es, "¿Cuándo podemos ir a ver esto?".
Y, por cierto, si somos amables,
tal vez, Cyril, ¿puedes sonreír y encontrar una cara feliz?
Oh, perfecto.
Por cierto, esto no se ensaya.
Felicidades, Cyril. Buena cosa. Oh guau.
Sigamos, de lo contrario, esto acabará con todo mi tiempo.
(Aplausos)
Por lo tanto, el arte y la cultura también pueden ser divertidos, ¿no?
Para nuestro último experimento rápido
--llamamos a todos estos "experimentos"--
nuestro último experimento rápido vuelve al aprendizaje automático.
Les mostramos los grupos, los grupos visuales,
pero ¿y si pedimos a la máquina nombrar también estas agrupaciones?
¿Qué pasa si se etiquetaran automáticamente sin metadatos reales?
Así que lo que tenemos es este tipo de explorador,
donde hemos logrado emparejar, creo que, alrededor de 4000 etiquetas.
Y no hemos hecho nada realmente especial aquí,
simplemente alimentar la colección.
Y encontramos categorías interesantes.
Podemos empezar con caballos, una categoría muy sencilla.
Se podría esperar ver que la máquina ha puesto
imágenes de caballos, ¿no?
Y sí, pero también se dio cuenta, justo allí,
que tiene una imagen muy abstracta
que ha podido reconocer y agrupar como caballos.
También tenemos una cabeza increíble relacionada con caballo.
Y cada una tiene las etiquetas de por qué se clasificó así.
Pasemos a otro que me pareció muy divertido e interesante,
porque no entiendo cómo se generó esta categoría.
Se llama "Dama de compañía".
Si, Cyril, lo haces rápidamente,
verán que tenemos imágenes sorprendentes
de damas, supongo, esperando o posando.
Yo realmente no entiendo.
Pero he intentado preguntar a mis contactos de los museos,
"¿Qué es esto? ¿Qué está pasando aquí?".
Y es fascinante.
Volviendo al oro muy rápidamente,
quería buscar el oro
y ver cómo la máquina etiquetaba todo el oro.
Pero, en realidad, no lo etiqueta como oro.
Vivimos en tiempos populares.
y lo etiqueta como "bling-bling".
(Risas)
Estoy siendo pesado con Cyril, porque me estoy moviendo muy rápido.
En esencia, aquí está todo el bling-bling
de todos los museos del mundo organizados para Uds.
Y para terminar con esta charla y estos experimentos,
lo que espero que sientan tras esta charla es felicidad y emoción.
Y ¿qué veríamos al mirar la felicidad?
Si nos fijamos en todos los objetos
que han sido etiquetados como "felicidad"
uno esperaría felicidad, supongo.
Pero hubo uno emergió que era muy fascinante e interesante,
era la obra de Douglas Coupland,
nuestro amigo y artista también
lo llama "Añoro mi cerebro preinternetiano".
No sé por qué la máquina siente que añora su cerebro anterior a Internet
y se ha etiquetado aquí,
pero es una idea muy interesante.
A veces echo de menos mi cerebro preinternetiano,
pero no cuando exploro arte y cultura en línea.
Así que saquen sus teléfonos, saquen sus computadoras,
visiten museos.
Y solo una rápida llamada a todos los increíbles archiveros
historiadores, curadores,
sentados en los museos, preservando toda esta cultura.
Y lo menos que podemos hacer es obtener una dosis diaria de arte y cultura
para nosotros y para nuestros hijos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)